all right let's talk about the
patriarchy a little bit this is the this
is probably the favorite topic of my
audience my audience just loves talking
about
the patriarchy no that's not true so
we're gonna look at a clip it's an
interesting clip jason whitlock was on
tucker carlson's daytime program now the
difference between tucker carlson's
daytime program and nighttime program is
that tucker
wears less formal clothes on the daytime
program but it's just as wacky it's
really no different jason whitlock is a
journalist who came from the sports
world and has become more and more of a
cultural critic the right wing
really has taken to jason whitlock he's
sort of like an anti-woke
tell it like it is type guy and the
things he tells like they are as he sees
them
are very often wrong and extraordinarily
reactionary
and jason whitlock on the tucker program
talked about how not only is he probably
a sexist but that the patriarchy is a
good thing and sort of like it's all
good because we need to keep women in
their roles
now this is a clip from 2022 it's not a
clip from 1952. and i know many of you
might say wow the video quality is so
good for what we would expect to hear in
1952. no this is from this week and um
tucker carlson
tucker seems to know he can't agree with
um uh
the guest openly because that could be
problematic for him but he does the
thing where he goes he says that's not
an opinion you're allowed to have right
now and so he's he's kind of like
indirectly saying like wow that's an
opinion you can really get in trouble
for but i don't disagree with it one bit
so let's just get into the clip and then
we'll we'll kind of pause as needed
but i probably am a sexist pig so i
could care less if i'm called that but
the patriarchy now he should be saying i
couldn't care less you would think a
journalist like jason whitlock would
know that but that's okay this isn't
about that it's about the substance good
thing
it's it's it's what god intended
uh
men are supposed to lead
men are supposed to be out front
taking risk
we're responsible that you know i have
some ministers on my show every
wednesday and we talk about it all the
time
and again this if you have a biblical
worldview it's shocking that the
ministers agree with the patriarchal
view huh
uh
in the garden adam and eve when things
go haywire
god shows up
and calls out adam where are you at
hey
basically he says i'm excuse my language
ain't right here
adam what are you doing
i left you in charge
and that's god is looking down at us
right now
at men and just what are you doing
why are you laying down
why are you pretending that hillary
clinton
kamala harris stacy abrams how do none
of them know how to pronounce kamala
harris by the way that they can save us
they can save this world this is lunacy
it's out of her role completely
and
uh i'm sorry if that paints me as a
sexist pig
but it's what i believe well that's just
i mean that's just an epithet designed
to make you be quiet but i guess i right
listen you know when you talk about how
these women are not fit to lead because
they're women and that they're trying to
be out of their roles um when people
call you a sexist they're just trying to
silence you it's just it's just an
epithet i wonder why why is that why are
you not allowed to have that opinion why
is that so controversial that was the
opinion of every society like from the
beginning of time until about 20 minutes
ago now that is that is actually what i
want to focus on what tucker says there
there's this bigger movement
about the natural patriarchy and this is
a movement that wants to
explain uh what might appear to be
um
unfair inequality when it comes to
gender
or
discrimination against women
they want to explain it away by saying
there is a
natural patriarchy
whether it's
um uh biological
or genetic or whatever the case meant
neurological and so that that this is a
very important movement and they wrongly
believe
the way tucker carlson says that it's
always been the way of humanity until as
he says 20 minutes ago until the woke
era until recently
and it's just not true now as many of
you know
i have no interest in repeating
um
tropes and talking points on this show
that aren't true so for example
when you don't hear this anymore
that much because i don't know society
has moved on but remember 77 cents on
the dollar you would always hear women
make 77 cents on the dollar compared to
men
it wasn't true
and we studied it and what we found out
was that women made about 91 cents on
the dollar now it's still an inequality
and there's a lot to look at and it's
well when when uh
what are some of the reasons why that is
and let's explore it and what portion of
that is due to discrimination on a
gender basis and what
listen let's explore all of it but i'm
not going to repeat 77 cents when i know
it to be 91 cents okay so i have no
attachment to any of these talking
points the natural patriarchy thing is
just not true first of all if you just
look in the modern era
on jobs there is no evidence that women
are less capable
of jobs and social positions that men
predominantly hold
i'm totally open to exploring interest
level
in some of those positions among gender
lines and when we talk about well
there's certain jobs that men versus
women are more interested in i'm totally
fine having the conversation as to
whether the difference in interest is
societally imposed by stereotypes
or
for some inherent reason
the right loves to say oh leftists don't
want to ask these questions ask them
when you think back to the larry summers
harvard comment
about uh something about math makes
women less suited or like whatever he
said
i have no problem exploring whether
there is some basis on which women are
less suited to math i've seen no
evidence that that's the case and so if
we don't have evidence we shouldn't
repeat it but the idea that these things
are taboo
they're not taboo for me and there is no
evidence that women are less capable of
the jobs and social positions that men
predominantly hold that i have seen now
it's also fine to acknowledge there are
biological differences between men and
women biological men don't breastfeed
biological men can't get pregnant but
this idea of the natural state of the
patriarchy is a lame one and it is also
a relatively recent thing there's some
very interesting evidence that
patriarchal societies
don't date back more than 10 000 years
humans appear to have been
significantly egalitarian
for a very long time if you go back and
look further and one reason that we we
suspect that is the relatively similar
size of human males and females yes
human males are bigger than females but
the disparity is much smaller of all of
the great apes and that is a clue it's
not proof but it's a clue
that male dominance
uh does not seem to have been as
important a driving force in the
development of humanity as people like
tucker carlson and jason whitlock might
might propose so you know it's not even
clear i needed to give this much
explanation but the things which jason
whitlock and tucker are just kind of
casually ranting about inciting god and
oh well you know they don't allow you to
say this anymore whatever uh these are
topics of academic interest and we do
actually know more than what jason
whitlock's pastor says
uh or minister whoever whoever is on his
show so uh i i don't know that uh
there's there's much value in this
program that tucker does but they
actually are raising interesting topics
their understanding of them is
completely wrong but these are
interesting topics for sure even if like
me you're not vegan and you're not
vegetarian
eating a more plant-based diet is a
really great thing to do for a number of
different reasons and our sponsor just
egg is the delicious plant-based egg you
can use it anywhere you use traditional
eggs because the taste and texture are
identical but just eggplant-based eggs
have the same amount of protein as
traditional eggs i use it all the time
at home you can make fluffy scrambled
eggs you can make omelets you can make
quiche frittata crepes
fried rice you should see my fried rice
recipe you can really use it anywhere in
baking or anywhere you would use
traditional eggs when i first tried just
egg i was surprised that a plant-based
egg could both taste and cook
just like traditional eggs you can get
it at the grocery store instacart amazon
go try it eating a more plant-based diet
is a great decision i do it and i'm not
vegan or vegetarian and just egg makes
it that much more easy and delicious